well Regional Mass have become an
increasingly important part of our
politics and especially of course with
some of these new Devolution deals
expanding their powers what Andy Street
a former John Lewis boss has been the
conservative mayor at the West Midlands
since 2017. not a traditional
conservative Heartland fair to say but
he joins us now live thanks very much
for being uh with us I'm Keen to get
your view on all sorts of things
um but just to start kind of big picture
the conservatives have had a pretty
disastrous set of local election results
and there is a real challenge for Rishi
sunac at the next election you of course
represent an area where you know you're
used to winning against labor you're
used to fighting tight uh seats and
scrapping for votes if you like what do
you think the conservative party needs
to do now to deliver and what it says
it's going to do and I don't just say
that as a sort of glib response I say it
on the basis of very firm evidence in
the West Midlands and the elections we
had three weeks ago now actually the
conservatives in the West Midlands
combined Authority era did not lose a
single seat we're held three
Metropolitan councils they're the only
ones in the country and the reason why
strong local leadership in those areas
were delivering on what people wanted to
say see it's quite interesting when you
say it's delivering on what you've said
already because there will be some
people who say you've got to change the
message look at what's just happened the
voters have basically sent a really big
message they're sick of what the
conservatives are doing they don't like
the direction of the government is
they're not times change course no
definitely not it's time to deliver on
the five things the Prime Minister has
said and again that the clear evidence
on the ground that that's what people
really are worried about NHS waiting
list as you've already been talking
about of course the migration statistics
as you've been talking about but also
all the underlying economic pieces and
my read of the uh of the results
actually we had good results in the West
Midlands as I say but across the country
there was no surge towards labor there
was disenchantment from our voters I
accept that but they're still waiting to
see if we can turn it around no so it's
normal slavery and still on course to
win the next time necessarily many of
the supply disagree with that they did
not do well enough to win the next
election on those numbers it was our
voters saying maybe not to get a
majority but to win and to get into
number 10. in a sense we're talking
about the process the question you asked
me is what have we got to do deliver and
I'm saying saying our voters are still
waiting to see if we can do that and I'm
very confident with time they will
certainly the direction of travel in
terms of where we were last Autumn and
where the prime minister's now got us to
is much better
um let's talk householding yes because I
know this is an area that you're very
interested in
um and it feels like there's a bit of a
battle within the conservative party
about what to do on a house building
whether or not you should support local
communities who are worried about
developments on the Green Belt whether
or not actually the conservatives needs
to build houses to really help at what
many families are calling out for where
do you sit so thank you for asking the
question because there's a story in the
Sunday Times this morning partly why I'm
trying to that tries to pitch me against
the government and frankly I'm amazed
that that's their take on it because
it's definitely not my view the first
thing to say is that the government is
achieving much improved housing numbers
compared to dare I say the last Labor
government 232
000 homes last year double the number in
2010 and the reason I think we've got
something to say on this is is that in
the West Midlands uniquely and the times
did confirm this we're achieving our
housing Target numbers and the way you
do that is you do have to take tough
decisions in favor of house bills what's
your message then because you say look
you need to take this topic and there
are many MPS who would disagree with
that on your side that actually look
we've got to listen to logical
communities one of the tough decisions
where we can definitely come together is
about Brownfield first I have been
absolutely robust about this over the
last seven years so have our councils
cross party in the West Midlands and as
a result of that it is encouraging
developers to attend to the tough sites
in the Brownfield areas that's not an
easy decision it requires densification
of our city centers that's been done and
of course it requires a lot of public
money to enable those Brownfield sites
to come back to use Bitcoin Greenbelt if
necessary occasionally okay you can
never say never so let's give a good
example huge investment going in around
ages 2 for The Interchange station in
solid Health the council there have been
very brave and say we will have
development around that to make the most
of it but it is very much the exception
to the rule if you don't get it right on
house building do you think that the
conservative party risks alienating a
whole group of Voters younger voters you
can put it much more positively than
that actually and it goes back to the
first question as well if I look at the
councils where we did really well we
were demonstrated bringing derelict land
back to life we were building the homes
we were doing the Regeneration of our
town centers and as a consequence those
young people see yes the conservative
party is the party that delivers for us
and that's the opportunity for us and
you talk about the economy as well
um and I want to talk a bit about
migration and because migration figures
are out next week they could hit 700 000
they're already at 500 000 which is unex
says that's too high and that they need
to come down but of course if you look
at the numbers
students work visas some would say that
this is immigration that we need what do
you think so the answer is it's again
it's not simple but binary like that we
do need skilled migrants in some key
areas so one of the sectors that the
government is talking a lot about at the
moment is the new industrial sectors
such as the electric vehicle sector we
do need people to come with those skills
but we actually have to deal with the
underlying issue about the lack of
skills in our own population so one of
the other things we're absolutely
focused on in the West Midlands is
reskilling retraining and that's the
real answer then you don't need to draw
in people in the way in which
historically we've been over dependent
um the other thing that I think is one
of those kind of big economic issues
that's been wrestling with is our
relationship with China I was quite
interested to hear if she's seen it this
morning saying China poses the biggest
danger of our age is he right or do we
actually need to do business with China
so the answer is both so let me just
explain of course he's right when he
says it's the biggest challenge of our
age because it's going to be the world's
economic superpower it is a superpower
that contrary to the relationship with
the US that has been the superpower for
the last hundred years does not share
our values that is obvious and so you do
have to think as a United West how are
we going to adjust tackle that issue my
opinion is it does not mean you
ostracize them completely and do not
deal with them economically but you have
to be absolutely alert so this question
about critical National infrastructure
who's owning that it's absolutely the
right thing to call out but it has to be
a policy of Engagement and what's your
view on taxes as well I know I'm doing
kind of like a jump everywhere yeah
they're all going everywhere but you
know it's rare that I get you in the
studio so I'm always Keen to kind of put
your brains on stuff
um what's your view on the levels of
taxes historically they're very high at
the minute lots of discontinental among
the conservative party do they need to
come down and which ones would you focus
on so no one's questioning the fact that
taxes are very high by historical
standards why because we've come through
a pandemic have spent an enormous amount
of money you've got to adjust to that
but the sad lesson of last Autumn is if
you do it in in an unplanned way you
just can't we'll be called out by the
markets so what the chance was said is
right he wishes to bring them down will
as soon as as he can as soon as the
public finances improve and where would
you go first I would definitely go to
business taxation first because actually
you stand back and say where's the
growth in the economy going to come from
it is only through businesses investing
and so that I think is the right thing
for him to have absolute in his sights
and when you say business taxes
corporation tax or what is there
corporation tax business rates are still
very challenging in many many areas
business rates and as the economy
adjusts there are areas that are really
stranded with their business rates so
that's an area where I hope we can move
but investment allowances uh would be
which are good they could move even
further it is as you say a very
challenging time for businesses at the
minute including John Lewis under quite
a lot of pressure I know you can do I'm
always interested to get your views on
as a former boss of John Lewis
um how how difficult is the situation
that it finds us well the situations
seven years since I
but never mind I can I can I can give
you a view if you ask a straight
question you need a straight answer so
uh yeah it's very it's tough for
retailers everybody knows that but there
are wonderful success stories if I just
look at Birmingham we've got severages
got primer we've got next we've got
Sports Direct all with Flagship shops it
can be done and you just have to focus
on delighting your customers sounds so
simplistic but in the good days of John
Lewis that is what was being done with
the best product the best service in the
marketplace uh now just finally and I
know that you will have a reason to not
know about this story I wouldn't expect
you to be texting suelo bravaman this
morning to find out the truth of whether
or not she did our civil servants to
organize the speed awareness course
but as a conservative you know fighting
in marginal areas for your position
how damaging are these stories
you almost answer your own questions
Sophie I cannot possibly know about this
I've literally heard it this morning uh
but I mean the point is very simple
there have to be standards in public
life uh I'm not going to sit here and
make a comment about the Home Secretary
I genuinely do not know what I do know
is the prime minister has made it
absolutely clear that for him standards
in public life is an absolutely critical
issue I hope that's how I conduct myself
I hope that's how my party conducts
itself but there is no compromise over
it because the public sniff out when you
are not doing that and if we serve the
public we have to reflect their best
standards and of course he said it and
he promised a government and he's he's
been a man to that